Leute, ich habe etwas entdeckt, was ich euch
zeigen möchte.
Aber erstmal herzlich willkommen hier in meinem
Freiluftbüro.
Hier trifft man mich eigentlich immer an,
wenn ich gerade nicht filme und nicht bei
den Tieren oder im Garten bin.
Und ich habe gerade hier diese Speicherkarte
durchforstet aus einem ganz anderen Grund
und da bin ich zufällig über Bilder gestolpert
von unserem jetzigen Selbstversorger-Küchengarten.
Aber bevor wir den angelegt haben, wir wohnen
ja seit etwas über einem Jahr hier.
Das heißt, der ist noch gar nicht so alt,
das ist noch überhaupt nicht lange her, dass
wir hier unseren neuen Garten angelegt haben.
Aber die Veränderung zu sehen, wie sich dieses
Grundstück entwickelt hat, war wirklich enorm.
Und deswegen bin ich gerade ganz motiviert,
euch ein Video zusammenzuschneiden, indem
ihr seht, wie wir den Garten angelegt haben,
mit was für Herausforderungen wir zu kämpfen
hatten und wie der jetzt aussieht.
Das ist ein Garten, der uns als Familie, wir
sind drei Personen, komplett mit Gemüse versorgt.
Wir haben noch einen Acker, wo wir unsere
Kartoffeln und Kürbisse und auch Zwiebeln
und Karotten anbauen.
Alles andere wächst aber hier und ich denke,
es ist sehr schön für uns alle, mal mitzuerleben,
wie sich das alles entwickelt hat und wie
so ein selbstversorgen Garten entsteht.
Also ganz viel Spass mit dem Video.
Ja, hier seht ihr unser Grundstück, wie es
aussah, bevor wir unseren Garten angelegt
haben.
Da stand eine alte Gartenhütte.
Da waren auch noch viel mehr Bäume und Sträucher,
die jetzt auf dem Foto schon gar nicht mehr
drauf sind, deren Wurzeln aber noch in der
Erde sind oder gewesen sind.
Und an vielen Stellen waren eben so Betonsteine
in den Boden eingelassen.
Wir haben an ganz vielen Stellen nichts anderes
mehr vorgefunden als eine Art Sandkasten,
auf dem vorher Steine gelegen haben für eine
Art Terrasse, wo dann dreißig Zentimeter
dicker Sand auf dem Boden aufgeschichtet war
und der Boden auch super arg verdichtet war.
Mein Sohn hat sich natürlich gefreut darüber,
ich nicht so sehr und die Pflanzen auch nicht,
denn in einem Sandkasten kann man kein Gemüse
anbauen.
Aber zum Glück haben wir schon reichlich
Erfahrung gesammelt wie es ist, in eher schwierigen
Verhältnissen zu gärtnern und deswegen wussten
wir auch schon, dass die Kompostbeete, die
wir super gerne anlegen, für diesen Garten
genau das richtige sind.
Ja, dann haben wir unsere Kompostbeete angelegt.
Das war ungefähr im Mai, also relativ spät
im Jahr.
Ende Mai war der Garten dann fertig.
Aber das ist ja eine Zeit, in der eben Gemüse
eigentlich schon lange in der Erde sind, so
dass wir uns dann wirklich sputen mussten,
um das Jahr aufzuholen.
Ich habe dann ganz viel gesät und gepflanzt,
mir die Saatgut-Tütchen geschnappt und gegärtnert,
was das Zeug hält.
Ganz viele Pflänzchen vorgezogen und ja,
es ist jedes Jahr aufs Neue so ein Wunder
zu sehen, wie aus einer Handvoll Samen ein
Garten wächst und wie alles anfängt zu sprießen
und zu grünen und zu gedeihen.
Und das war super, super befriedigend, die
ersten Monate so zu erleben.
Ich zeige euch einmal unseren Garten, als
der ungefähr, ich glaube, der war ja so zwei,
drei Monate alt.
Da sah der Garten schon so aus.
Also schon ein Riesenunterschied zu dem Grundstück,
wie es vorher ausgesehen hat.
Und das jetzt nochmal zu sehen, das macht
mich so stolz gerade.
Ich bin einfach super happy.
Und dann auch die erste Ernte einzufahren,
es ist einfach ein ganz tolles Gefühl, das
man nur nachvollziehen kann, wenn man selber
auch gärtnert.
Wir haben dann im Sommer ein Gewächshaus
aufgebaut, ein viktorianisches Gewächshaus,
von dem ich schon ewig lange geträumt habe.
Und das hilft uns enorm, das ganze Jahr über
zu gärtnern, im Sommer wie Winter.
Im Sommer stehen da unsere Tomaten und sind
super gut geschützt vor Wind und Wetter.
Im Winter können wir in dem Gewächshaus
immer noch eine riesengroße Palette von Gemüse
selber aus unserem eigenen Garten ernten,
was natürlich, wenn man versucht, das ganze
Jahr aus dem Garten zu essen super, super
wichtig ist.
Aber, und das ist etwas, was mir wirklich
sehr am Herzen liegt.
Ich will die Selbstversorgung, so fantastisch
es auch ist, sich selbst zu versorgen.
Ich will das nicht romantisieren hier auf
diesem Kanal.
Denn Selbstversorgung ist richtig harte Arbeit
und ich glaube, das geht oft ein bisschen
unter hier auf YouTube, wenn man sich all
die schönen Videos anschaut.
Natürlich will ich niemanden entmutigen,
selber das eigene Essen anzubauen und sich
ein stückweit selbst zu versorgen oder vielleicht
sogar zu versuchen, möglichst viel selber
anzubauen.
Aber man muss wissen, dass es schon sehr,
sehr viel Arbeit und auch Erfahrung braucht,
um das wirklich richtig hinzukriegen.
Wir haben zum Beispiel dieses Jahr dreimal
unsere Gemüse vorgezogen und gepflanzt und
jedes Mal sind wieder die Hühner unserer
Nachbarn gekommen und haben alles abgefressen,
und weggekratzt, weggescharrt, so dass keine
einzige Pflanze übrig war und nicht nur mit
den Jungpflanzen, sondern auch mit größeren
Pflanzen, die wir im Winterbeet überwintert
haben.
Und das war super frustrierend.
Das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel von tausend
Sachen, die schief gehen können und die auch
schief gehen werden.
Denn wir haben jedes Jahr solche mehr oder
weniger grossen Katastrophen in unserer Selbstversorgung
erlebt.
Aber ich will dir sagen, wenn du solche Sachen
erlebst oder wenn es vielleicht Schnecken
sind, die dir alles wegfressen.
Die innerhalb kürzester Zeit über deinen
Garten herfallen und dir bleibt nichts übrig
als so eine schleimige Spur, die dir noch
verrät, wer der Übeltäter war.
Ich weiss genau, wie frustrierend das ist.
Und ich weiss auch, wie wichtig es ist, trotzdem
weiter zu machen und sich nicht entmutigen
zu lassen.
Es gibt ja dieses Sprichwort, das heißt,
glaube ich, ein Garten zu pflanzen bedeutet,
an die Zukunft zu glauben.
Und an manchen Stellen in unserem Selbstversorgerleben,
in unserer Selbstversorgererfahrung ist es
mir extrem schwer gefallen, mich wieder aufzuraffen
und zu sagen, ich glaube daran, dass es nochmal
funktioniert.
Auch wenn es schon dreimal schief gegangen
ist säe ich jetzt nochmal alle meine Gemüse
aus und werde die wieder in diesen Garten
pflanzen in der Hoffnung, dass sie diesmal
unversehrt bleiben und wachsen können.
Und es ist manchmal superhart, das zu machen
und sich in den Hintern zu treten und zu sagen,
hey, lass dich davon nicht entmutigen, du
machst jetzt weiter.
Aber es ist es so was von wert, wenn man dann
sieht, es hat geklappt.
Unser Garten ist jetzt natürlich um einige
Wochen hinterher, als wie ich ihn eigentlich
haben wollte.
Aber es hat geklappt, es wächst Gemüse in
unserem Garten, ich bin wieder zufrieden.
Und gerade auch wenn du Tiere hältst, gibt
es so viel, was schief gehen kann.
Wir haben letztes Jahr, als wir Zicklein bekommen
haben, hatten wir eine Ziege, die ihre Kleinen
nicht angenommen hat.
Und das war herzzerreißend zu sehen, wie
diese kleinen frisch geborenen Ziegen, die
keine Stunde alt waren, versucht haben, an
ihr zu trinken.
Und sie hat sie einfach nur weggeboxt und
das eine sogar versucht zu töten.
Und wir haben die dann mit der Flasche aufgezogen.
Das ist natürlich unglaublich niedlich, so
kleine süße Tiere bei sich zu Hause zu haben.
Aber es hat mir doch so wehgetan zu wissen,
dass sie eigentlich bei ihrer Mutter sein
sollten.
Und dadurch, dass sie so menschenbezogen waren,
hatten wir auch sehr große Probleme, die
ziemlich ja, fatale Folgen hatten, nämlich
waren die so menschenbezogen, dass sie jedes
Mal, wenn Leute an der Weide vorbeigelaufen
sind, in den Zaun gesprungen sind, weil sie
unbedingt zu den Menschen wollten.
Weil sie dachten, das ist meine Herde, ich
will da hin, das ist meine Familie.
Und eines Tages kam ich da hin und der kleine
Bock, das ist der, mit dem weissen Popo, nicht
mit dem braunen, hing, stranguliert tot im
Zaun.
Und sowas bricht einem wirklich das Herz.
Also das sind ja auch Tiere, die einem super
ans Herz wachsen und trotzdem gehört es dazu.
Es sind immer wieder Tiere bei uns gestorben
und das ist etwas, womit man irgendwann dann
irgendwie leben lernt.
Und gerade mit den Tieren hat man immer wieder
Ärger, gerade mit Ziegen.
Also wenn du dir irgendwelche Tiere zur Selbstversorgung
anschaffen willst, dann überleg dir dreimal,
ob es wirklich Ziegen sein müssen.
Ich hab die nur, weil ich denen leider total
verfallen bin.
Weil ich sie unglaublich arg liebe und ja,
wie gesagt, ich habe seit 14 Jahren Ziegen,
ich kann nicht mehr anders.
Aber bevor du damit anfängst, überleg dir
das lieber dreimal.Aber
trotzdem ist es so erfüllend, sich selbst
zu versorgen und es ist so ein schönes Gefühl,
wenn du deine Pflanzen hegst und pflegst und
siehst, wie sie wachsen und gedeihen und so
eine enge Verbindung zu deinen Tieren hast.
Und dann deiner Familie die erste Ernte auftischst.
Wenn du dann merkst, wow, jetzt habe ich so
viel Ernte aus meinem Garten, dass ich das
für den Winter haltbar machen kann.
Dass ich da meinen eigenen kleinen Wintervorrat
anlegen kann, ganz viele Schätze haltbar
machen kann aus meinem eigenen Garten.
Und es ist ein superschönes tolles Gefühl
und es gibt einem so einen befriedigenden
Rhythmus über das ganze Jahr, wo immer wieder
die gleichen Dinge anstehen und man super
abhängig von den Jahreszeiten ist, aber eben
auch super davon geprägt wird.
Wenn dann im Herbst die Zeit ist, um die Samen
zu ernten von dem Gemüse, das man selber
angepflanzt hat.
Wenn man seine eigenen Sorten weiter vermehrt,
Jahr für Jahr und weiter entwickelt an den
eigenen Garten anpasst.
Und meinem Sohn zu vermitteln, dass das superwichtig
und wertvoll ist, mit der Natur zu arbeiten
statt gegen die Natur.
Das ist ein Geschenk, was ich jedem Kind wünsche
und wo ich unglaublich froh bin, dass ich
das meinem Sohn ermöglichen kann, so aufzuwaschen.
Es ist ein süsses kleines Wuschelbärchen,
das schon viel Zirkus gemacht hat.
Es heisst Harald das Küken.
Ich glaube drei paar Tage und einen halben
ist es alt geworden und das kleine Wuschelbärchen.
Sich aus dem eigenen Garten selbst zu versorgen,
gibt deinem Leben einfach einen wunderschönen
Rhythmus.
Du hast den Winter, in dem kaum Arbeit anfällt.
In dem du dich ausruhen kannst und träumen
kannst von deinem neuen Garten, wenn dann
irgendwann die Saatgut-Kataloge ankommen.
Wenn du deine Saatgut-Tütchen ordnest und
deinen Garten planst, deine ganzen großen
wilden Träume aufzeichnest von dem Garten,
den du im Sommer haben möchtest.
Dann die Zeit im Frühling, wenn superviel
zu tun ist, weil du die ganzen Pläne umsetzten
möchtest und die Gemüse in die Erde pflanzen
möchtest und säst, was das Zeug hält.
Wenn dann die erste Ernte ansteht und im Sommer
der Einkochtopf quasi rund um die Uhr läuft,
weil du gar nicht mehr weisst, wohin mit dem
ganzen Obst und Gemüse und du manchmal auch
ein bisschen den Mut verlierst, wenn vielleicht
Sachen nicht so gut laufen wie sie sollten.
Aber du dann wieder an Fahrt gewinnst, wenn
du merkst, wieviel Ernte dein Garten abwirft.
Und dass sich das Jahr schon wieder dem Ende
neigt.
Dass die Pause wieder in Sicht ist, die man
auch braucht im Winter.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir im Winter nichts
anbauen, aber man hat viel, viel weniger zu
tun im Winter.
Und das tut auch gut.
Das ist auch wichtig, damit man sich im Frühling
dann wieder auf das neue Gartenjahr freuen
kann.
Und was vielleicht am schönsten ist, ist,
dass egal, was für Fehler du dieses Jahr
machst, egal wie fatal die sind und was alles
schief läuft.
Du bekommst jedes Jahr eine komplett neue
Chance.
Es ist komplett egal, was du dieses Jahr alles
falsch gemacht hast, im Frühling kannst du
nochmal komplett von vorne anfangen.
Und das kannst du jedes Jahr machen.
Du wirst jedes Jahr aus deinen Fehlern lernen
und du hast jedes Jahr die Chance, dieses
Jahr zu deinem besten Gartenjahr überhaupt
zu machen.